whitney's very last performance was on  stage with kelly price in a small  nightclub and it was completely  unplanned i feel like that's kind of a  gift that god gave me  because even if we didn't know he knew  um and so it gave me one last  opportunity to share a very intimate and  special moment  with her  [Music]  i was having a grammy celebration party  i had three nominations that year and  she called me and she said i'm gonna be  there for you  and i was like yay  so she was there and we had a ball i  wasn't expecting her to sing at all  um she came up on the stage she made her  way to the stage and she was like give  me the microphone i would have never  asked her to take the stage i would have  never stuck the microphone in her face  everyone that was there was performing  that night  and uh  she started she took the microphone and  she started to sing yes jesus loves me  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you